all right well
hey everyone thank you so much for being
here today as james said i'm denying
mataxa
i'm a phd candidate in computer science
here at stanford
and i'm gonna be presenting some of the
work that i've done during my phd
studying bias and representation in
sociotechnical systems
so as an introduction i'd like to get
started by telling you a bit about how i
arrived at this topic of study
the computer science department at brown
university where i earned my
undergraduate degrees
has a tradition of giving each course a
fun theme every year
this was generally a really popular move
with students
and there were pop culture topics like
television shows or comics
i really enjoyed most of these themes
myself but i also found that some of
them
were a little bit intense so
for instance this one that had a james
bond theme although honestly that's kind
of clever for a security class
or this one modeled after star trek
or especially this one this was a very
intense matrix theme
wait it gets worse i hope you can see
that animation it actually ran in the
background of the website at all times
[Music]
so these were all real course websites
while i was at brown
and it's not that i had any particular
issue with the matrix or with star trek
but
it was that despite the fun environment
i had noticed many of my friends in
those courses
ended up dropping out of the courses or
out of the major
and this seemed especially true for my
women classmates
and there were also so few women faculty
or teaching assistants
so given that context some of those
websites gave me a sort of intuitive
feeling of unease
one that i knew didn't have anything to
do with the actual material of the
course but
it was still there years later when i
started my phd
i came across a concept from psychology
that helped me give language to that
intuition
ambient belonging is a term that
describes the feeling of
fitting in with a culture or a community
that's passively elicited by the
surrounding environment
it's a psychological concept that comes
from a broader literature on
belongingness
and that goes back to abraham maslow's
hierarchy of needs
belongingness describes the
psychological need to be accepted as a
member of a group
so at the start of my phd i found this
prior research that had examined ambient
belonging in physical spaces like
professors offices
cherian at all found that student's
sense of belonging could be negatively
impacted by classroom cues
stereotypical cues in offices and
classrooms like what books were on the
table what posters were on the wall
these could have a negative effect on
potential students in particular
students from marginalized groups
now obviously classrooms and offices are
immersive and they reflect personal
information about an instructor
in a way that web pages aren't and don't
but based on that idea i decided to
design an experiment to see what effect
ambient belonging might have when
transmitted through a user interface
so i designed two versions of the same
course web page
for an introductory computer science
course at stanford
the first used neutral imagery and the
second stereotypical imagery
both of these were designed and
pre-tested to look appealing and
engaging to students
and the content on the pages was
identical i only changed the aesthetic
design
my hypothesis was that these should have
different effects on potential students
more specifically that the stereotypical
interface would be detrimental to women
but not to men
so that would mean hypothetically
producing results figures that look
something like this
comparing those two interfaces the
neutral one in the lighter color
stereotypical in the darker color i
expected there'd be very little
difference in the two bars for men
that's the pair on the left
who are you know pretty comparable
height but the for women that's the pair
on the right
that the stereotypical interface would
have a negative impact
and on the y-axis here is a seven-point
likert scale for each experimental
measure
after interacting with one of those two
websites assigned at random i had
participants answer questions on that
seven-point likert scale about a range
of measures including
whether they thought they would want to
take the course whether they expected
they would feel comfortable in it
how well they expected they would do but
also a set of measures beyond the scope
of the course
whether they felt confident in their
technical abilities whether they even
wanted to study computer science and
finally whether they felt they would be
judged according to gender stereotypes
in the discipline
also note here that rather than
potentially negatively impacting a whole
cohort of actual stanford students
i ran the experiment using crowd workers
of undergraduate age in the united
states
and what i found was striking so
starting with these course-related
measures
women exposed to the stereotypical
websites suffered
as you can see for each measure the
right most uh dark bar that corresponds
to women who saw the stereotypical
website is statistically significantly
lower than all the others in the figure
so that means they reported lower
intention to enroll
less sense of belonging less anticipated
success relative to all other
participants
moreover women who saw that
stereotypical website were also
negatively impacted on longer-term
measures the ones that
ostensibly had little to do with the
course they said they were less
interested in computer science as a
field
less confident in their technical
abilities and they expected to be much
more stereotyped in the discipline
and all of these were moderate to large
effect sizes as large as any in the
prior work on ambient belonging in
physical spaces
by the way you might notice that exposed
to the neutral website if we just
compare the two lighter green bars in
each figure
women's and men's responses were mostly
comparable without statistically
significant differences
so for a field that emphasizes its
pipeline problem it's
impressive to note that we don't
actually see evidence here of
pre-existing differences by gender
so i was able to conclude that gender
bias could negatively impact people's
sense of belonging
through a user interface but of course
belongingness as we said
isn't specific to gender a wide variety
of biases can be conveyed visually and
impact belonging
you can consider for instance the effect
of an image like this one
of paul ryan's interns when he was
speaker of the house on a young person
of color who wants to enter government
and
really doesn't see themselves
represented in that image
or this grandiose image from the rhodes
scholarship website
and the effect that could have on a
promising student of lower socioeconomic
status who's never set foot in a place
like oxford and their sense of belonging
in a community like the rhodes scholars
visual cues in online systems can have
unanticipated and unintended
consequences
on users across a range of dimensions
that project launched further work from
other researchers like renee kiselkatch
at cornell studying psychologically
inclusive design
but it also launched my own research
focusing on bias in sociotechnical
systems
and its psychological effects
so what are socio-technical systems
let's take a step back
broadly these are systems that shape and
are shaped by users
they interface directly with the user
and in turn they're often shaped by user
behaviors
this includes for instance search
engines and social media sites
and in my work i close that loop by
studying the system
and the user i combine building systems
with behavioral science theory and
methods focusing on users
to address high-stakes social issues in
sociotechnical systems
and in doing so i'm looking to answer
two main questions
the first what kind of content do
sociotechnical systems produce
and the second how does that content
impact users
towards building systems that do better
now
traditionally in a software system we're
used to asking the first question
we know what it means for a system to
work and we conduct tests and use
monitoring to verify that it does
actually function as expected
socio-technical systems meanwhile
because they're in a loop with users the
users are literally part of the system
it's not enough that a platform just
functions to evaluate them effectively
we also need to ask
first what those outputs look like at
scale and second
what influence they have on users by
answering those two research questions
we can learn how to build sociotechnical
systems
that have positive impacts on ourselves
and on our communities
now before i give you a roadmap for the
rest of this talk let me explain why
this work is so challenging
in the example we started with comparing
two websites we can see that content
that's created by a single person
like a course instructor can communicate
bias and undermine belonging
but this isn't an individual scale
problem most sociotechnical systems
today aren't showing us hand curated
content
they provide us content that's been
selected and organized
algorithmically
and we rely on that algorithmic content
for basic social functions
like connection to family and friends
gathering information
and civic engagement in the united
states as of 2019
over 70 of americans used some type of
social media and a similar proportion
got some of their news through social
media
and as of 2012 which is unfortunately
the most recent pew data on search
engine use
over 90 percent of online adults use
search engines
that's a number we can somehow imagine
is even higher now
and over two-thirds of those searchers
considered search engines to be fair and
unbiased
but these systems do have significant
biases we've started to see concern
about bias along the lines of
gender race political affiliation and
more
studying these systems going beyond
criticism to precisely measure the
content that they produce
and to quantify the impact they have on
people remains a challenge
i see four key problems here two on the
side of the system
and two on the side of the user
first these systems are dynamic they
change constantly which can pose
significant technical challenges in
trying to study them
and second their byproducts are
ephemeral a user's experience of their
news feed or search engine results
disappears without a trace after that
interaction there's no way to examine it
retrospectively
now on the side of the user they are
embedded these systems are in a loop
with users and users are interacting
with dozens of such systems
simultaneously in a single browser or on
a single device throughout their daily
lives
and finally they're personal each user's
view of the system is unique
and in fact the impact it has can be
very different from one person to
another
to meet these challenges and close the
loop of socio-technical systems research
we need interdisciplinary solutions that
tackle both sides of that equation
and this is what i do in my work in this
talk i'm going to show you what this
looks like in practice touching on four
projects from my phd
first in the introduction i describe my
work on belonging and bias in web
interfaces
next i'm going to talk about my most
recent paper on race and gender
representation in image search
third i'll bring in some of my work on
partisanship in political search results
and i'll finally describe the project
the final project in my dissertation
building
infrastructure for intervention audits
so let's move to that second project on
race and gender in image search
one social issue that's received
attention in various fields is visual
representation
in particular the representation of
marginalized groups in media as i showed
in my study of course pages
visual cues impact belonging in the
field of advertising
prior work has shown that representing
marginalized people in college brochures
can make a university seem more
appealing to students
the same has been found to be true for
employees at a company
and also for customers of a business
these kinds of cues are important for
marginalized people
they indicate that an organization might
be more welcoming to them
but importantly the effects of visual
representation are not restricted to
those groups alone
visual diversity signals inclusivity to
everyone
given the importance of algorithmic
systems like search and my interest in
visual representation
i was drawn to work on image search
results do image search results
accurately reflect
real world diversity prior work from
2015 had identified that search results
for occupations
exaggerated gender stereotypes since
then and often in response to research
findings like this one google has made
many changes to their algorithms
but we might want to ask are image
search results still biased in their
presentation of gender
moreover our field has often left race
chronically understudied
do image search results accurately
reflect real world racial diversity
to answer these questions i first needed
to collect a ground truth data set with
which to compare search results
the us bureau of labor statistics tracks
demographic breakdowns of several
hundred common occupations
doctors lawyers real estate agents and
so on
so based on that bls list i set out to
collect image search results from google
using as the query term the names of
those occupations
in my introduction i described that
process of identifying bias in hand
design content
but in this case i wanted to study the
composition of hundreds of images for
hundreds of queries
this is where studying algorithmic
content becomes technically challenging
so to accomplish this i built
infrastructure to collect that
algorithmic data
my pipeline for automatically collecting
and processing image search results
begins with a scraper to query google
with each of those query terms and
capture the resulting top 100 images
to avoid potential personalization from
repeated searches
i used a selenium webdriver with
separate sessions for query
the scraper saved each image to cloud
storage where they were then
automatically retrieved in the next step
data annotation
to annotate the data i recruited crowd
workers through amazon mechanical turk
with three workers assigned
at random to label each of those
thousand images
i elected to use crowd workers here
rather than automated image processing
or machine learning because
ultimately i'm interested in how other
people perceive these images
for gender crowd workers were asked to
label whether each image showed a woman
or not
for race whether the image depicted a
person of color or not
now this is obviously a reduction down
to a single bit does this image
represent a marginalized person
yes or no there are many potential ways
to improve this strategy in the future
but i use this binary categorization
because
while both race and gender are spectra
in each case there is a single dominant
group that others are marginalized in
relation to
and i collected up to three labels
considering the annotation to have
reached consensus when two-thirds agreed
and finally after eliminating
occupations whose image results didn't
show enough people
or enough people with discernible race
and gender i settled on a final list of
occupations
i made sure then that these occupations
were not statistically significantly
different from the full list of bls
occupations in terms of demographics
so putting that all together what does
this look like
beginning with gender i had a list of
occupations with their real-world
workforce gender diversity
from 0 women to 100 on the x-axis here
and i could map each to a place on the
y-axis reflecting the proportion of
women in
image search results for that occupation
the colors of these data points are
arbitrary just to help you track each
point when they move in a second
the diagonal line represents perfect
correspondence this is where the data
points would line up if image search
results were perfectly reflective of the
real world
above this line are cases where search
results overrepresented women
and below where search results
underrepresented women
so let's see some data for example
receptionists are about 88
women but google images for
receptionists were almost 100
women on the other hand women are 30
of ceos but only 11 of search results
and women are more than half of all
bartenders but only a quarter of search
results for that query
doing the same thing for race we again
have a set of occupations with their
ground truth workforce demographics
and again the diagonal dashed line would
be a perfect accordance between the bls
and google above is over representation
and below is under representation of
people of color
you might note by the way that the axes
here don't range from zero to one but
rather go up to forty percent
that's because people of color are only
twenty two percent of the us workforce
on average
and so there aren't records of
occupations that are more than 40 poc
and again we can map those to
demographics observed in search images
so what we see here is that for most
occupations people of color are
underrepresented
take chefs for instance people of color
are highly represented in that
occupation at 37 percent
but they're still heavily
underrepresented in search
there are of course some cases like
among librarians where we see that
people of color are a very small
fraction of librarians but google
actually over-represents them in search
next to quantify the degree of
under-representation in both cases
i fit generalized linear models to the
data predicting google representation
from bls data so
looking at these figures visually we can
see that there's generally an
under-representation of women and people
of color relative to the workforce
even more so in the case of race than of
gender
in order to test whether the model's
predictions of the overall workforce
average those are the vertical dotted
lines
whether that was significantly different
from proportional representation
that's the diagonal line i examined the
model's predictions at that x value and
found that indeed
these predictions were statistically
significantly lower
so summarizing this for digestibility we
can say that for an occupation with 50
women this model predicts that images
will show 42 women
for an occupation with 22 people of
color the model predicts that images
will show
16 people of color and in both cases
these differences are statistically
significant
even more strongly in the case of race
than of gender
so going back to that question do search
results reflect real world diversity
in this data set we find that no images
systematically under represent women and
people of color
relative to workforce participation
rates
the process that i used to answer this
first research question about the
content sociotechnical systems produce
is called an algorithm audit algorithm
audits are the process of providing
repeated inputs
and measuring outputs of an opaque
system to draw inferences about its
inner workings
auditing without the algorithm part is a
powerful tool that's been used in the
social sciences for decades to identify
discrimination
in things like employers hiring
practices or loner's lending practices
in the context of algorithms we adapt it
to examine whether an algorithm displays
bias
so having answered that first question
using an algorithm audit
in this project i also closed the loop
by connecting a second study answering
this second question
how does biased content impact users and
how can we do better
first to do this i selected a set of 10
occupations
5 for race and 5 for gender in which
marginalized people are heavily
underrepresented
i chose these ones as i felt they were
among the most high impact examples
since women and people of color might
already feel that they don't belong in
those occupations
next i created synthetic image search
results pages
using the actual images that we
collected in the earlier study
for each of the 10 occupations i created
three synthetic search results pages
one with images predominantly from the
dominant group one with images
predominantly from the marginalized
group
and another with equal representation
and i designed a randomized controlled
study for each occupation
exposing participants in the studies to
one of these three conditions at random
after that exposure i then asked each
participant questions about three
measures of interest on a seven-point
likert scale
first i asked about their perception of
how inclusive the occupation is
second about their interest in joining
the occupation and third whether they
felt they would belong or be valued in
it
so what did we find first let me explain
how to read the figures i'm about to
show you
the first dimension i varied gender is
shown here along the x-axis
so we can see how participants
perceptions of occupation inclusivity
changed as the proportion of women in
those synthetic search results increased
second each of these search results also
had some distribution of
racial representation that's shown here
with three different lines showing
participant responses on the outcome
measure
as the proportion of people of color was
increased
so reading this figure all together what
can we see
we find that greater representation of
marginalized groups
makes occupations seem more inclusive
across the board
reading all three lines from left to
right across the figure we can see that
participants expectations of inclusivity
in this case
generally increased the more women they
were shown
and next examining these three lines
separately we find that showing search
results with greater representation of
people of color
also had a positive impact on
inclusivity in particular showing medium
or high levels of people of color's
representation
had a positive effect on perceived
inclusivity relative to low levels of
racial representation
and we also validate these findings
statistically we fit a linear model to
this data that predicts perceived
inclusivity from these two features
and both race and gender representation
in the images had a positive and
statistically significant impact on
expectations of inclusivity
you'll also remember that this is
consistent with prior literature on
visual diversity making organizations
seem more inclusive
next let's look at results in the same
format for the second measure
participants reported interest in an
occupation
here we see somewhat different results
while increasing racial representation
does slightly increase interest in the
field as you can see from those stacked
lines
increasing gender representation
actually had a borderline negative
effect on people's interest in the field
and again fitting a model to predict
interest from gender and race
representation in the stimuli we
confirmed this finding
so in this case search results with more
women had if anything a negative effect
on our outcome measure
what might explain that one possible
explanation
is occupational feminization this is a
set of theories in social science that
describe the cultural turn that happens
as women become more represented in
occupation
and the closely related idea that pay
and other status markers decrease
as women's representation increases so
although we might have good reason to
believe that increasing women's
representation in image search results
is a normatively good idea
in some cases it can empirically lead to
counter-intuitive and even
counterproductive outcomes
now going back to the setup there's
actually one piece missing here
so importantly in addition to exposing
participants to different conditions and
collecting their responses
i also collected demographic
characteristics like race and gender for
each participant
while the previous two results i showed
were largely consistent across
participants
on issues like belonging i hypothesized
that people from marginalized groups
might be affected in significantly
different ways than those who aren't
so next i'm going to show you two
findings about participant's sense of
belonging
specifically examining differences first
by the participants race and gender
first by participant gender and then by
participant race in addition to the
stimuli
so first let's examine sense of
belonging as women's representation was
increased
separating participants by gender as you
can see
women's representation in images had a
significant effect on participants
belonging in the occupation
but that effect was heavily moderated by
participant gender
when shown search results with very low
representation of women
men were much more likely than women to
say that they felt belonging
but as i increased the proportion of
women in those search results women's
belonging
increased while men's decreased to the
point where they almost converged
so we find that women's sense of
belonging improves with greater
representation
while men's declines what this means is
that
we can actually compensate for
pre-existing differences in gendered
perceptions of belonging by
increasing visual representation of
women what it also means though is that
increasing women's sense of belonging in
this way
might happen at some cost to men's sense
of belonging
and again fitting a linear model to the
data we see that gender in search
results and participant gender
both had a significant effect on sense
of belonging as did the interaction of
those two
finally i did the same analysis for race
separating participants by whether they
identified as white or people of color
and examining the effect of
increasing racial representation in
image search
unlike the case of gender however i did
not observe a significant effect of
image diversity on participant sense of
belonging
racial gaps in belonging were unchanged
by visual representation
across the board white participants
reported a higher sense of belonging
than people of color and no amount of
racial representation in those search
results could change that
and again we confirm this finding
statistically
so to conclude these findings confirm
that visual representation and
algorithmic content can change people's
expectations of the world
and of their place in it but as we saw
there are also some important nuances to
keep in mind first
more isn't always better greater levels
of marginalized people's representation
can actually have deterring effects
because of underlying social issues
second identity moderates effects the
same content might affect people from
different identity groups very
differently
and third there are cases where existing
inequity simply can't be addressed
through some intervention
technical fixes won't suffice for big
social problems so
as i've just shown you i use a
combination of technical and behavioral
science tools to answer these two
questions
what content socio-technical systems
produce and how that impacts users
underlying the insight that visual
representation impacts users there's a
key theoretical idea that i want to draw
your attention to
users in the experiment i just described
as well as in other previous work
aren't consuming search results by
scrutinizing each result individually
and thinking about
what source each image came from and
deciding whether to adjust their world
view accordingly
instead empirically they consume the
entire page of results at a glance
the whole page is essentially a single
object
in my research i've given a name to this
idea i call this
search media search media is the
combination of headlines
text and ordering of results on a page
that's experienced by users as a unified
form of media so when users think search
results are largely unbiased
and then they draw inferences about the
real world from the mosaic of images in
search
consciously or not they're treating
search results as a type of media
that positions google in a role similar
to that of a newspaper publisher
presenting users with a front page for
every query
now for various legal and policy reasons
google would heavily resist that
characterization
but i would argue that that's what the
data suggests is how users are
psychologically experiencing search
in addition to potential policy
implications for google this also has
implications for how we conduct and
analyze algorithm audits
rather than focusing on only one part of
the search page
and waiting the top and the bottom of
the page equally we need to think about
how users are actually consuming that
content
for example by considering the whole
page and waiting results at the top more
than once at the bottom
this idea about search media and the
algorithm audit strategy for studying it
has
implications in many domains outside
visual diversity
for instance another area of interest
for me is politics
in the political context one important
kind of representation that matters
is the representation of political
perspectives and the potential for bias
is along partisan lines
so in the third project i'll touch on
today i studied political partisanship
in search media in 2018
then u.s president trump tweeted about
google
he made a series of claims on twitter
that of course got picked up by major
news outlets around the country
alleging that google search was biased
against conservative perspectives
amidst that contentious political
context i did an audit of political
partisanship in web search
first to find a real world data set of
importance i collected the names of
every candidate running for federal
office in the u.s 2018 midterm elections
that's every candidate running for
either chamber the house or the senate
in any state that year to collect a data
set
i built infrastructure to perform
queries with those politicians names
collecting the first page of search
results scraping data at this scale
entails several technical challenges
one risk is that google will identify
this irregular activity
and block the scraper another is that
a single machine conducting each of
these 3 000 queries wouldn't actually
finish in the course of one day and i
wanted to collect these scrapes daily
so to do that data collection of over
3000 pages of search results daily
i used five scrapers instantiated using
amazon ec2
and coordinating between them such that
the scrapers rotated through a list of
ip addresses and user agent strings to
appear as though these queries were
coming from a set of over
20 actual machines i also instituted a
random wait time of about a minute
between queries
since rapid queries without wait time
make it likely that google will detect
and block that irregular behavior
and finally each query included a
depersonalization parameter
as if we were querying in incognito mode
to prevent personalization by the
history of queries
i wasn't too concerned about other forms
of personalization since prior work had
shown that generic political queries
like these are not heavily personalized
i then repeated that data collection
every day for the six months leading up
to the election for a total of over four
million urls
finally i used an established metric to
label each of these urls with a
partisanship score
that's a measure from very liberal to
very conservative that describes the
ratio of liberals to conservatives who
normally engage with that website
i did this with the goal of
investigating the set of sources from
which search media was being compiled
from what sources does google create its
search media for these political queries
for instance if google was biased
against conservative news we might
expect there to be very few sources on
the right side of this figure
or if google showed large partisan
differences for republicans and
democrats
maybe this would reflect some disparate
treatment of political groups
instead however what we found is that
search media drew
extensively from conservative sources
regardless of query
as you can see this pattern also looked
roughly the same regardless of the
affiliation of the candidate being
searched for
so at least by these metrics we can
conclude that there isn't some
widespread bias against conservative
content in search media
in other words algorithm auditing can
also identify when there isn't evidence
in support of some alleged bias
now you'll remember i said i collected
this data daily for six months leading
up to the election
i was interested in whether there were
any temporal changes over the course of
the election
and i did find evidence that political
events affecting individual political
candidates changed their search media
but rather going into those here i'll
just touch on one striking trend across
the whole data set
here we have the average partisanship of
each page of search media
weighting each individual search result
by its order on the page
so a page of more partisan search media
would be a data point higher up on this
figure
whereas a more moderate page would be
lower and i looked at partisanship over
the course of the election for
candidates who went on to win their
elections
versus those who lost
as you can see we found that search
media clearly differentiate these two
groups
election winners have much more moderate
search media than do losers
now before you get excited and quit your
day job to start the next 538 election
prediction service
i have to tell you something that
political scientists would recognize
very well
it's a well-established fact that
election outcome has a very strong
correlate
and that's incumbency incumbent
candidates
win upwards of 90 of the time or even
more
so if we separate candidates out by
incumbency we actually find that this is
the main driver of that trend
search media differences reflect
incumbency incumbent candidates
have much more moderate search media
than do challengers or those running for
open seats
this finding empirically demonstrates a
pattern that's been theorized in
political science
that challenger candidates whose road to
electoral success involves first winning
a primary election where only members of
their party are voting
are incentivized to take more extremely
partisan positions
whereas incumbents who are looking to
win a more general election where
citizens from both parties will be
voting
should take care to come across as more
moderate
in short our findings from this study
demonstrate that algorithmic content
reflects real world information
and reveals insight that speaks to
theory from other disciplines like
political science
and overall algorithm audits are a
multi-purpose tool
for studying bias in sociotechnical
systems
without going into this too extensively
i want to make a note here on algorithm
auditing
as we've seen conducting effective
algorithm audits is technically
challenging
what should we measure how do we collect
that data how do we manage it at scale
and at times it's also theoretically and
ethically challenging as well
for instance it usually involves
breaking a platform's terms of service
which
historically was illegal so recently
i've gathered a team of leading
algorithm audit researchers from four
universities
and we've written an authoritative piece
on algorithm auditing
including its history best practices
ethics and
norms so you can look forward to that
piece in the journal foundations and
trends in hci later this year
as i said at the beginning of this talk
there are four key challenges to
studying socio-technical systems
they are dynamic ephemeral embedded and
personalized
research like mine closes that loop
connecting the socio and technical parts
of these systems using a combination of
computational and behavioral science
strategies
but the overhead to doing this work as
we've seen is significant
so for each website we want to study we
need to build new custom infrastructure
and that infrastructure only allows us
to study one website at a time
and in order to control the stimuli that
users see we have to run experiments in
highly controlled artificial
experimental settings
so in order to enable researchers to do
this work and to do it more sustainably
in addition to creating guidelines and
best practices we also need more
effective tools
this need for tools brings me to the
final project in my phd creating
infrastructure for intervention audits
while there are existing tools for such
research they have significant
limitations
there are many examples of one-off
infrastructure for passive audits as
we've seen in this talk
and these can be really valuable but
they generally only collect data from
one website at a time
new infrastructure has to be built for
every new audit and any experiments or
interventions need to be run separately
another option is panel survey data
collected by private companies
such data can be reanalyzed by
researchers who don't have to collect it
all from scratch
but in such logs we can only see what
websites users visited
not images headlines or other content
consumed without visiting a new url
and these data sources also don't allow
for experiments and can be really
expensive to get access to
and finally i think some of the most
promising work has been proposed
recently by mozilla who are developing a
tool to let researchers collect data and
run experiments in the browsers of
volunteers
this gives researchers a lot of control
and allows for interventions which is
great
but using volunteers limits data
collection and intervention to things
that mozilla will approve
and users will tolerate on a volunteer
basis plus researchers can't follow up
with participants through surveys or
other kinds of additional data
collection
so going back to those challenges
ideally what we want to do is allow
researchers to collect data themselves
in real time
to do this for extended periods of time
perhaps following up with the same users
later
choosing exactly what data to collect
from user browsing across all websites
and being able to combine this auditing
with interventions on consenting
participants
and that's intervener intervenor is the
last project in my dissertation
it's a system designed to allow
researchers to both passively audit
and also intervene on the cross-site
browsing experience for a group of
consenting
compensated participants the system has
three parts the first
is a front end a django web app the
second is a chrome browser extension
and the third is the back end
implemented with amazon web services
relational database
i'll explain briefly what these three
parts do
the front end is user facing with an
admin interface for researchers
it handles onboarding and off-boarding
collects survey responses
gives users privacy controls for their
data and allows researchers to manage
participants
the extension handles data collection
collecting the trail of links that
participants visit online
time stamps and also content on the page
customizable by the researcher
this could include images headlines
links or other content viewed by
participants
the backend then combines and securely
stores these two data sources where
researchers can access them later for
analysis
to make this a little more concrete i'll
walk you through intervenor's use from
the perspective first of a participant
and then of a researcher
so from a participant's perspective
their experience of intervener has three
parts
onboarding participation and
off-boarding
during onboarding they are consented and
they complete an onboarding survey
and then they're walked through the
extension installation process
during participation there are two
phases first the extension
passively collects data from their
normal browsing to establish a baseline
for each participant
and during the second optional phase the
system deploys interventions
changing their browsing experience
finally after their participation is
over they uninstall the extension
complete an exit survey receive payment
and can potentially be contacted with
follow-ups in the future
from the perspective of the researcher
intervener involves development
recruitment and management during
development rather than build this whole
infrastructure from scratch the bar for
entry is lower
researchers just need to be able to edit
the existing code to collect the
specific data they're interested in
and deploy their own interventions
next they can generate participant codes
to allow users to sign up
distributing those through ads survey
panels crowdsourcing platforms or
wherever else they're getting their
participants
and finally during the experiment in
management phase researchers can do
things like randomly assign participants
to different experimental conditions
and collect and analyze the resulting
data
to make these benefits clear let me walk
you through two examples of studies that
intervener can enable that are beyond
the current state of the art
the first is in the domain of fake news
and misinformation
there's been a lot of work in this space
in the past few years including an
excellent recent paper that analyzes
browser history logs published by alan
at all in science which concludes that
people visit websites with
misinformation pretty infrequently
but intervenor allows us to go further
first
in terms of exposure what headlines do
people see but not visit
browser history logs only record sites
that people do visit
in contrast intervenor can collect data
on each page of a user's browsing
and study things like selective
avoidance by examining all of the links
that people see
but don't click on next intervenor is
user centered
in addition to log data we might want to
deploy surveys or
interviews uh to understand how people's
beliefs change over time in relation to
the content they consume
unlike history logs intervener has
built-in capabilities for this kind of
additional data collection that can help
us better understand the user's
experience
and finally interventions in addition to
studying media consumption patterns as
they are
intervenor gives us the capacity to run
ecologically valid experiments for
example periodically prompting users to
focus on content accuracy
which other recent work suggests is a
promising strategy to counter
misinformation
following that work i'm also going to be
reusing an extending intervener to study
bias in online advertising we've
probably all noticed or heard at this
point that
marketing and branding is often heavily
gendered and related concepts like
whitewashing describe the way that
dominant norms
what's considered attractive
professional or marketable
are also racialized and affect the way
that we see race presented in media like
movies and ads
moreover the content we see in
advertising should have some
psychological impact
that's kind of the whole point of
advertising so
given that backdrop and the harms that
i've shown you can occur from biases and
gender and racial representation in
algorithmic content
i'm interested in whether online ads
shown to people also display such biases
existing work has found that from the
perspective of an advertiser
online advertising platforms don't have
sufficient safeguards in place to
prevent advertisers from
racially targeting ads for things like
housing and employment though doing so
is illegal
and similarly that ads for things like
stem careers may not be shown equally to
men and women
but if we wanted to study the set of all
ads actual users are shown
current algorithm auditing techniques
fall short as you've seen
most algorithm audits collect data from
a single website and that data is
presumed to be a good stand-in for what
all users see
in this case though ads are shown to
people across the whole web not just one
site and they're highly personalized so
again intervenor improves the current
state of the art
first on exposure intervener can collect
all the ads people see in browser and
get a full picture of the content of
those ads
for instance we can look at things like
the distribution of gender and skin tone
in those ads and ask whether they're
representative of diversity
second intervener will deploy to a group
of real users collecting all the ads
they're shown across all the websites
they visit
and allow us to study those repeated
exposures in the context of those users
own demographics
to understand for instance whether
people of different races or genders are
shown significantly different ads
or affected by ads differently
and finally we can also experimentally
change the ads that people see
to causally demonstrate the effect that
such ads can have on people's
perceptions of this technology
and of themselves
the last point i want to underscore
about intervenor is about the importance
of privacy
research practices in academia as well
as industry have led to major tensions
in recent years when users are unaware
that they're participating in
experiments or
unable to opt out keeping that in mind
intervenor is designed with participant
privacy as a central value
this includes consenting and
compensating all participants
providing those participants with
controls over the data that we collect
including an interface for data
redaction and incognito browsing
and securely and anonymously storing
their data for a limited period of time
i plan to release a version of this tool
publicly allowing other researchers to
run studies hosted in the intervener
environment
practices like these are necessary for
making that research sustainable
by creating trusting relationships with
participants who we can work with again
in the future
so to summarize over the course of my
phd i've worked on studying
representation and bias
in sociotechnical systems including the
four projects i've talked about today
the first three demonstrate the impact
of combining computational strategies
like algorithm audits with behavioral
science to identify bias in algorithmic
content and its impact on users
first i showed how psychologically
inclusive versus alienating design could
impact people's sense of belonging in a
course
second that racial and gender biases do
appear in algorithmic content
and can have detrimental effects on
people in the context of employment
and that different levels of
representation can cause positive and
negative psychological responses
and third that building systems for
auditing bias in algorithmic content
is also a useful tool in cases where
some alleged bias isn't observed
but that such content can reflect real
world and theorized trends
and finally intervener takes this one
step further providing much needed
infrastructure for researchers to be
able to conduct this important work
in a more accessible scalable and
sustainable way
sociotechnical systems and the
algorithmic content they produce
are going to continue growing as one of
the main sources of education
professional opportunities civic
engagement and more
so when we study it it's vital that we
consider both sides of that equation the
system
and the user and that we do so keeping
in mind and in focus the experiences of
marginalized users
this is the central aim of my work by
closing that loop between algorithmic
content and its effects on people
we can build socio-technical systems
that have positive impacts on ourselves
and on our communities
thank you so much for your time and
attention
just quickly before opening for
questions i'd like to take a moment to
make a few acknowledgments
first to my advisors who have guided and
supported me so well over the last six
years
and made me feel valued not just as a
researcher but also as a person
i also extend my thanks to the rest of
my committee for all of their advice
and guidance starting even before my phd
and for their patients as i finish my
written dissertation this summer
and i'd also like to acknowledge my
other collaborators especially the
students that i've been so lucky to work
with
as well as the interaction design lab
the social media lab and the stanford
hci group
working with all of you has been the
absolute best part of the phd for me
and i'm so grateful to know each of you
and finally doing a phd is certainly
more than just a professional
undertaking
i am so supremely grateful to the
friends and family who have supported me
throughout
so thank you again so much for your time
and attention i'm happy to take
questions now and also feel free to
contact me by email
or to find me in person this coming year
at stanford during my postdoc or next
year when i start as an assistant
professor at penn
thank you
all right thank you so much deny
[Music]
the sound of a very enthusiastic clap
i'll take one from the q a form just to
kick us off and then
uh folks can feel free to jump in so
our first question is just wondering
whether there's any research
um basically looking at the correlation
between that sense of
belonging and then uh these impacting
and applying to or getting into a
grouper career so if
you know if the sense of belonging goes
from four to five on a like at scale
uh on a liquid scale what impact is that
going to have on their behavior or
outcomes
and they say i appreciate that may not
be the answer to this yet
yeah that's a great question uh
belonging has been studied pretty
extensively in psychology and so i would
point you in that direction for other
research but that that was exactly the
reason that i included measures
that were you know beyond the scope of
just that course to think about whether
someone said that they would want to
enroll
um but also to think about whether
someone felt that they were even
interested in computing at all
because it's those changes that
belongingness can make to the place that
we see ourselves and the way that we
imagine ourselves in the future that i
think is really
interesting and promising or you know
important to study yeah i had a question
um in the first project
where you were showing search results i
was curious
what your methods were for creating for
example the collections of images
of you know marginalized populations and
so on because that in itself can be a
very complex
and biased process yeah definitely
so the process there was uh first we
took the set of actual images that we
had produced
um by scraping in the first part then we
looked at the breakdown
of uh populate of marginalized people
that we wanted in each of those three
conditions
and we selected that set of images kind
of starting from the first row of search
results and continuing through
so basically we were trying to get
something as close to that first set of
search results that people would see
while also including the right number of
marginalized people for that
uh for that experimental condition and
so sometimes this meant going further
down on the page to find enough
marginalized people
to put in the search results because
there really weren't very many
um and then from there we were
randomizing in their presentation on
that
uh set of search results when you said
the number that you wanted how did i'm
confused by
like how you determined what you wanted
yeah yeah those were the three
conditions
let me see maybe it's worth uh to pull
up this
slide um or maybe this one
um we were looking for the low condition
to have approximately 10 percent the
medium or equal representation condition
to have 50 50
and the high to be 90 marginalized
people
oh yeah so my question is like of the
marginalized people how did you choose
because you could have
different you know there's different
categories of marginalized people
yeah yeah we were just selecting those
from the order in which they appeared
in the results that we had initially
collected yeah so that's an important
point though to make because
um so the fact that for instance we
don't see
uh here is the slide i'm looking for
we don't see a difference um in changing
representation we don't see an impact on
people of color
i think in part that's because you know
i'm talking about here as if we're
talking about the
representation of marginalized people
but in fact really what we're looking at
is the representation of white people
and decreasing that so that doesn't
necessarily mean affirming the
representation of particular
marginalized people
the same way that we would ideally want
to say you know let's take each
individual's own
uh identity category and over represent
that particular thing
i think that that's kind of like the
next important step in this case we
actually didn't have enough
um images of different types of
marginalized people in order to be able
to do that
we also couldn't be sure exactly how you
know from some set of images
for each individual participant who they
would say they identified with and who
they wouldn't
but i think that's kind of the ultimate
goal is to understand
each person has you know nearly infinite
dimensions of their own identity and so
we'd like to be able to understand for
each person
what aspect of their identity is salient
in that particular context
and how do we highlight that particular
thing to sort of optimize for
things like belongingness thank you
yeah thank you so much that's a great
question
i have so many questions i get to choose
from um
wondering i'll just quote it much of
your research maintains race and gender
as discrete categories which seems
necessary for the algorithmic approach
to measuring differences in
representation in socio-technical
systems
but does this appreciate increased
homogenization that erases women and
non-binary people of
color and reify power differentials that
lead to this underrepresentation
and can the algorithmic approach be
modified to accommodate people who are
non-normative intersectional or
or not discernible in their race and
gender presentation
yeah that's a fantastic question and one
that i appreciate very much myself
these are definitely simplifying
assumptions that we're making in order
to sort of discretize the problem and
make it approachable as a first step
as more and more of this work is being
done once those initial effects are
established i think we have a lot more
leeway to sort of first of all to
examine identity in more nuanced and
more
multi-dimensional ways but also i think
to do follow-up work that specifically
focuses only on marginalized people's
experiences
while anchoring it to this sort of like
broader literature that we've sort of
started to establish
you know about like everyone because
unfortunately in science
you know the understanding of who is the
default person
i think if you go straight into the work
that only looks at marginalized people
sometimes your work gets pigeonholed as
being you know like
really very uh not interesting to a
broader population and it's really only
like for a specific subset of people who
care of this kind of like identity issue
um so yeah these are limitations i think
not only of
um the fact that much of this work
hasn't been done before but also of the
need to try to pitch this work
and establish it to a broader audience
and so that's something that i'm really
cognizant of sort of bitter about and
trying to change
a few others um did you ever follow up
with brown cs about their websites
that's a fantastic question yeah
wondering because that one will be fast
wondering um the slide about
relationship between google and
conservative sources was interesting and
does this mean that google search
results are right-wing biased
great question um the uh first question
about whether we have followed up with
brown cs i know that they have been made
aware of this work
um i don't know that they have made any
concrete policy changes as a result
i mean even while i was there i was
arguing on the course staffs that i was
part of that like you know we should at
least be thinking about this dimension
and i hope knowing the students of brown
i'm sure they are
but uh the department as a whole hasn't
really changed anything that i know of
as of now um and whether the uh
whether what really we're finding is
that google is biased towards
conservative perspectives
um the figure that i showed you there
was
uh double counting was looking at not
the set of unique sources but like how
many times they came up
and so that's not adjusted for something
like the number of political candidates
from the different
groups um so i can't conclude that
necessarily if we look at
i have similarly the figure you can see
this in the paper the figure of uh
unique counts of sources and we find
roughly the same
total weight on like the more left side
of that figure and the right side of
that figure it's like about even in
weight i think actually what they're
trying to do
is to actively balance because this is
something that they're aware of
which could be its own kind of bias like
i don't condone balance is the right
answer but it's
uh i think that's what's going on i'll
jump in with a with a quick question
um i really loved your talk overall uh
super super great i in your in the
earlier part of your talk you mentioned
specifically
looking at um i think maybe it was even
the previous slide to this were you
looking at male and
female distinctions here um do you have
a sense
for the longevity of these kinds of
effects like
if you're looking you know if you're
doing this and you suddenly see
imagery that doesn't quite match what
you believe but if you know versus
having seen that kind of imagery
for years i don't know how you would
measure that but i'm curious if you have
a
saw i thought there yeah that's a
fantastic question so there's two things
there right one is like
from a single exposure how persistent is
that effect
and we haven't measured that in this
case although i expect it shouldn't be
that persistent
um there has been some previous work
that followed up with people a few weeks
later and did actually find some effects
so you know perhaps it's even on the
scale of weeks
but the other point you make is around
uh repeated exposure
and i think that's the really important
and powerful thing because we do
interact with these systems so
repeatedly you know on a daily basis
for decades even um
and so that's kind of one of the goals
of building interveners to be able to do
that kind of longitudinal follow-up with
the same people
and also to be able to record the
content that they're actually seeing
in a sort of ecologically valid way in
their browser over the course of all of
their web browsing
in order to understand whether we're
seeing these biases consistently across
that data and whether those repeated
exposures are having
more of an effect we would expect they
should compound yeah
all right i am going to call time uh
and the committee denies committee will
now adjourn into private session where
um they will continue to demolish us in
all of our questions
and uh but we'd like to thank deny for
for sharing their their
their presentation with us and uh
we look forward to seeing what you get
up to at penn that's gonna be super
exciting
thank you
you